l'action grâce à toujours été un
durement à passer à Saint-Bernard
l'action de grâce c'est pas de la
tristesse et de la joie c'est des
merveillement mais pour nous ça vient
chercher vraiment cet événement là mais
25 ans après la tragédie qui a fauché la
vie de 43 de ses citoyens et de leur
chauffeurs la communauté souhaite passer
au prochain chapitre 16
qui arrive là il y a d'autres choses du
positif qui arrive Michel Leblond œuvre
et à l'église de Saint-Bernard lors du
drame des cérémonies anniversaire il en
a vécu plusieurs mais il estime que
celle-ci devrait être la dernière
génération qui
est passé au 25 ans alors on veut
boucler le boucle on a choisi
de choisir la vie alors il s'est passé
des belles choses depuis 25 ans c'est ça
qu'on va se débrider à la demande de la
communauté le père Marc-André la chance
a officié la messe 25 ans après avoir
les funérailles des victimes
à côté de l'Europe 43 bougies à la
mémoire des disparus et le siège allumé
par la dernière survivante pour
symboliser la résilience de la
communauté moi ce matin j'ai un théâtre
parce que plein de personnes là qui vont
s'être ajoutées des enfants des
petits-enfants que je pense qu'après 25
ans leur
ça va être terminé comme grand grand
événement dans l'Église c'est toute la
vie qui est venue de plus en là c'est
une génération alors dans ma propre
famille il y a plein de petits-enfants
qui sont nés Georgette Blondeau a perdu
11 membres de sa parenté dans l'accident
il y a une belle solidarité qui s'est
installée c'est comme ça qu'on a pensé à
travers jeudi une cérémonie est prévue
aux Éboulements où l'accident s'est
produit une minute de silence sera
observée à 13h50 l'heure ou le drame
s'est joué ici Flavie Sauvageot
Radio-Canada Saint-Bernard